the point of that [ __ ] story I told
you being on top of that Hill at 17 and
being homeless mm-hmm is because I had a
lot of chances to ice myself show I had
a lotta has chances to ice myself they
could get not a [ __ ] prison and think
of me getting out on bail when I gotta
have a bail I had a lot of [ __ ]
doubts my friend didn't get that on bail
and knowing you're gonna look at the 48
[ __ ] he's a hero [ __ ] loser as it
is think of all those opportunities I
used to break into a friend's house to
sleep in his house at night I slept in a
rocket ship for a month outside at a
park you park you see those rocket ships
and your kids play on them
I still go up to the third floor rocket
ship finishing off my coke and jerking
off on the third floor at 5:00 in the
morning outside in a [ __ ] park with
leaves around me and [ __ ] it was a lot
of times I had it's amazing you have no
[ __ ] idea I would go up to the third
floor with a bottle of [ __ ] Smirnoff
silver vodka a bag a hooded sweatshirt
gloves with a missing finger so I could
[ __ ] touch the rock and look up in my
nose and [ __ ] you know that's all funny
on the way up the stairs is [ __ ] but
when you when you come down and you're
in that rocket ship that's 5:00 in the
morning it's 20 [ __ ] to below zero
oh and you just take him to yourself
[ __ ] God took away my mother God did
this this is all God's fault because
it's the same God that I was raised to
believe that was gonna help me he's
doing all this but a lot of times I
wanted to [ __ ] him do a swan dive but I
didn't you know it's so [ __ ] weird I
was in those positions for a long time
yeah now I gotta look at you and go
Jesus Christ look at black Irish no no
Tina Turner's son killed himself
yesterday it was a nice son though I
thought it was Ike son with her
you know this trend the [ __ ] people
icing themselves that scares me a
concerns me is this some were eating
this it's something that we're getting
weak on you know there was no drugs in
Bourdin system so we can't blame [ __ ]
prescription drugs he was on one
medication some sort of medication and
it was something that was prescribed for
him someone told me that it was malaria
medication I don't know probably don't
know if they've released that but I'm
sure he had to take some of that stuff
sometimes but you know you don't know
what it was that did him in I mean what
does looking to some people he really
wasn't doing well you know I don't know
I need to I mean it's almost unnecessary
to get from mediate the full story I
miss the guy he's gone that's it you
know I mean I don't need to I think
whenever whenever someone does something
like that whatever it is if there's one
thing that people could point to and say
hey there's a chemical that's
responsible for this or there's a gene
problems it's responsible for this or
they're like how could someone who's
loved so much want to step out I mean
that must be a terrible moment of pain
right and it just keeps playing songs
and you know control I think I started
with lemon skin at a simple man right
kept going another one let's get a trip
and I when I came back and at one point
blow up the outside world ah
and I'm sitting there and he says that
one going out or something Joe Rogan my
lip started shaking like I'm like I
don't even know this guy know this guy
you want me to look you people and tell
you I know I'm a Creole I met Chris I
don't know I don't know I never saw him
one time I'm at the Comedy Store six
feet away from me Chris Cornell that's
it and I started crying like how could
something like this go in a room and
just ice themselves is this what I'm
gonna do because I'm in this [ __ ]
entertainment field because what what
happens and then I think about all these
times one time I broke into my friend's
house and I broken the window and it was
freezes I couldn't even sleep in that
room
sleep in the hallway and there was a
mattress on the wall that had like piss
stains from all the kids and I pulled it
down I slept on it when I woke up he had
a dog and it was too it was too cold he
just let the dog [ __ ] downstairs and
there was like 20 pieces of the little
rolled up [ __ ] that had been you know
like when the juice goes out of them
they just roll up what's those things
that uses it organ or those accordion
accordion it was like a piece of [ __ ]
shrinks like an accordion when the
moisture goes out of it it really does
so if you take a [ __ ] that's this big
all right and you put in a box come back
a week later it's like this big how do I
know that cuz I did it to a guy in
prison
I took my [ __ ] in the welfare box one
time you know Jesus no the boxes of
cheese where the cheese comes in
American cheese yes this dude had long
hair and will always try to play me like
key boobies with the biker dudes in a
box for him but he played he where he
lived in the key worked in the kitchen
he forgot I ran the kitchen and it was
all me and black dudes so one day I got
one of the well fat cheese boxes and I
took like the 20 to 24 inch it looked
like a lizard it just it was just long
like you know then at the end like one
of those things that like a snail that's
it like a long brown snail and I fit it
perfectly into this cheese box and I
took a flag of the American flag like
the cheese and I pull up and I put it
this draw Oh every night I Drive and he
had the first bunk on the way out so
everybody had a walk and all the black
guys were open they're doing go god damn
smells like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and he kept saying I know it does I
don't know why it smells like [ __ ] in
here and after like a month when they
would not draw better become saying man
he smells like [ __ ] in here he went in
his drawer opened it up and he found
this box he opened it up and I never
forget him knocking I'm like monk going
I'm gonna find out who did this to me I
know what they do to you and he goes
look at this like what is it my no we
[ __ ] shrunken down from the 24 inches
till like six little inches it just
shrunk down all the moisture goes out it
just shrunk down like a [ __ ]
I don't even know why I'm telling you
that story it's a hilarious story it's
[ __ ] crazy it's a hilarious story